appreciate you joining us so yeah that's
one of the insulting things everybody
says you know Dave I'm driving a hoop to
you I'm driving a David car that is not
a Dave car that's so insulting you're
Dave car is when you get the brand-new
$120,000 Mercedes because you have a
four million dollar net worth and you
pay cash for that and you don't think
anything about it
that's your Dave car because you've
lived like no-one else now you can live
like no one else you drove like no one
else so now you can drive like no one
else I do not expect you to have a five
million dollar net worth and be driving
a two thousand dollar car that isn't I
mean if you want to I'm not gonna be mad
at you but don't call out your Dave car
because I teach you to live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else and I own several
vehicles now but I drove crap for a
while I mean I drove one the predominant
color on it was bondo but I was too
broke to do anything else and I don't
borrow money and if you add up all of my
vehicles boats cars trucks sea-doos
whatever else it's got a motor in it
around my life and add it all together
everything with a motor and it goes down
in value you can just count on it and
it's still less than one percent of my
net worth and so you know it's just
stuff but you know one of the reasons
you work your butt off is to enjoy a
couple things and I'm a car guy I love a
cool car I'm just got you know really
bad I mean I grew up redneck hillbilly
and so you know there's just something
about a loud muffler that just does it
for me you know it's just I probably
ever I got to my friends got Tesla's and
I'm not gonna get one cuz they don't
make any noise I mean they're cool and
they're fast but they don't make any
noise I want to make noise and leave
tracks wherever I've been you know I
mean I yeah I don't get it it's faster
than some of the cars I own but I may
get one someday maybe I'll maybe I'll
get over it but I I think they need to
put like a little machine in there that
makes noise and then rednecks would by
Tesla's right so there you go this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]